je suis père athée par l'école la
maîtresse elle était malade
mc non c'est pas vrai j'ai un cadeau
pour toi christophe locaux bien six mois
bonjour aujourd'hui
bah voila c'est rose elle vient
s'occuper de toi jusqu'à noël
max je t'ai dit julie qui suit on compte
masisi cassure et sam travail secret bd
bandol
je trouve leur compteur ouais j'y suis
pour rien je suis déjà bien gentil de la
ramener bien connus y sava province et
bassines parce que c'est pas possible
c'est si c'est pas possible c'est pas ta
vie tu fasses ici c'est pas pourquoi
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
vous emmerde dames on fera pas une dame
ça se fait pas ils pourraient ça se fait
pas tes liens deux hommes toi max
j'étais déjà expliqué c'est pas possible
parce que parce que pour s'occuper des
bonshommes et ben ça va coûter trop cher
à ton papa il n'a pas les moyens aux
tissus ou prenons en compte au sort
j'essaie de vous aider là c'est pourquoi
trois mois mac os x comme le nez au
milieu de la figure vous êtes fauché non
mais y'a qu'à voir votre gourbi
ils ont bien sûr il fallait pas dire de
gros mots côté ce gourbi ce un choix de
déco d'accord sinon je peux vous dire
quelque chose
vous avez vraiment des goûts de chiotte
ravaux drapeau vous enlevez les déjà
comme l'est par m'avouer mac ça suffit
maintenant c'est mon cadeau
j'ai donné ma soeur verra rose pour
qu'elle vienne s'occuper de toi jusqu'à
noël
il prépare mon cadeau va pas s'il te
plaît papa il va pas partir aux s'il te
plaît papa
bon moi m'a pas partir aux rimes demandé
mon avis c'est quoi vous à mon avis mon
avis c'est ce qu'il faut voir tous les
soirs